you're watching Sky News for the
National act of remembrance from the
Cenotaph in London as Her Majesty the
Queen looks on to lead the nation in the
annual recollection of all those who've
laid down their lives for their nation
for peace and for the protection of all
[Music]
[Music]
the wreath of Her Majesty the Queen as
the leader of the nation will be laid on
the top step against the Cenotaph by the
Prince of Wales while Her Majesty looks
on
and the queen will continue to watch as
the wreath for her husband His Royal
Highness the Duke of Edinburgh who saw
considerable active service in the Royal
Navy during the Second World War and was
present in the Pacific at the point of
victory against Japan the 75th
anniversary of which we will reflect
upon next year
His Royal Highness the Prince wears will
lay his own wreath with the white badge
of the heir apparent in feathers placed
upon it all his life his sir firstly
with the Navy and then through his links
to all parts of the Armed Forces has
kept closely in touch with their work on
operations and informed when anyone was
injured or killed the Duke of Cambridge
the Duke of Sussex and the Duke of York
each of which has played a part in
serving the nation as so many of their
generation have